if you watch the show in the season the
way it ends
linda and i were like you know we don't
know we don't know if there's another
season
we
i'll say i was like i don't think
netflix wants to do another season of
this i didn't feel that energy i was
like i get the sense that this is the
end of the road and so we ended it the
way that we ended it so that we would
have an ending
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
roses are red violets are blue don't let
a wild pube wreck you that's true don't
let some pubes that are out there watch
out you know peeking through your
underwear don't let those wreck you so
valentine's day is around the corner
manscape which i'm a huge fan of has the
best tools to get your balls your
werewolves the boys the junk
ready for the special occasion so it's
valentine's day join the four million
other guys whose huevos are sparkling
clean and sparkling sheen watch out at
least when you sit on yourself when your
manscape the people can see the bruises
the leader in below waist grooming
with the exclusive offer with an
exclusive offer guilt
go to manscape.com and then put in the
code what omghi for 20 off plus free
shipping
your lady and your webbles and your
neighbors who peek in on you and you
don't know well thank you
hey
how about nobody like that [ __ ] guy
man what guy the other guy that [ __ ]
with that animated show
are you going
the other time listen man how do you
have
cartoon
esteban mr cartoon of stevon
mike judge
mike judges do dustin
me
and we talked to marvin we talked to
some other [ __ ] guy
and they chose the other guy and the
other guy
everybody hated it really [ __ ] hey
listen
isn't that why you vet [ __ ] people so
that when you pick somebody they're like
hey you know what man
i don't know dude everybody hates that
guy what do you mean everybody hates him
ask around he comes back everybody
[ __ ] hates him we hired that
[ __ ] we went to netflix we had a
good pitch that guy was like
you know
me and cartoon you're a step on and
jordan you know we come from the same
we're like we [ __ ] like we're like we
cover the same what
become the same
a woman
and he would throw himself in there man
and then we would afterwards we were
like what did you hear that goes bad no
good man what
and they said hey man nobody likes that
dude man you he goes well you guys chose
a [ __ ] dude nobody likes what do you
mean nobody likes them
nobody likes them damn that's wild i yo
that i totally forgot about that i was
doing that i pitched you when i was
still brother in post on the show and i
was squeezing in all the things and uh i
i kind of forgot that i had pushed to
you guys on that we we [ __ ] up we
[ __ ] that one up all right so so
felipe is here felipe like i said is one
of my favorite
[ __ ] people of all
of all time one of my favorites and
marvin and i just met in person here but
we have you know mutual things going on
and
and you know we talked about trying to
do um the show
and then gill's here because you know
you give him a [ __ ] hat he don't go
away
[Laughter]
you know this because he's trying to
sell me a [ __ ] another head goes oh
this is the one you gave me [ __ ]
no i had a thousand hats about and i can
tell you every hat that i've ever given
to somebody he's like no there's another
one
that's like felipe [ __ ] eggs
[ __ ] what's up you gave me the hat i was
wearing the hat religiously the one that
you gave me because i liked it and then
i liked it
i liked it so much i went out and i
bought another one and that's when you
said is that i said no this is another
one that i bought
this one
i just got this week it looks good
[Laughter]
okay he's fluffy and now you're going to
be muffin with them
no no you're better than beef squasher
everybody says we're messing around yeah
washer
you know i got something you hit a guy
with a [ __ ] head with the with the
sap and what happened
it flew
makana you know these come all kinds of
things i didn't want to be hit by one
and they're only illegal because they're
so [ __ ] effective that you can't have
somebody who's not a law enforcement
officer in it whatever bouncer you could
have a little and anito as a bouncer at
a club
if you had one of those you could use
them anywhere you wanted to and they had
two sizes they they had they actually
had three sizes they had one that was
about i'd say about eight inches long
it's called a 415 disturbing the piece
415 that's penal code section then he
had one that was a little bigger that
one was called a 245. that's assault
with the deadly weapon then they had a
chin guard
nobody imagined you bought these just
for displays it was called a 187. that
was a two-fister oh my god if you hit
somebody with that one are these are
those the ones that like they like
they're like telescopes no no no
that's a good one too those are illegal
too right those are all the [ __ ]
illegals those are the nazis
that's not what we
i remember i had i knew a kid i don't
know why i had forgotten about this
until you were talking about this but i
remember a kid had one and i don't know
where the hell he found it it was just i
don't know in high school or something
and like ours the the lights are gonna
pop off no no no not with the new ones
no when they came out that mag light
that was the first one machine tool
flashlight the old silver streams the
one that used to see the cop put under
their arms
and they put tape around them you know
so they wouldn't slip out
you hit somebody with that and it all
fall apart batteries that go this way
lights would go that way
those are no good but the new ones are
better the black ones yeah the ones that
have like in jail where they wake you up
with
yeah did they ever use one of those
[ __ ] cow prods or like what the [ __ ]
would you call it
no no i didn't use those heroes
i've seen well i was just gonna say what
you when i was in [ __ ]
like
when i was in juarez like an old toaster
they got two [ __ ] i'm eating bread
these regular cow cow prods when i was
in waters the guy that i went over there
with we were there to pick up a witness
they ended up bringing a murder suspect
off for us
and he says hey that's a guy i'm telling
you that's the guy that takes him out
and tortures him in the back with a with
a prod [ __ ] tortures and i said holy
[ __ ] and he brought this murder suspect
in between about five of us
and we're sitting there in the
commandant that said just tell him hey
so remember when you got away with
murder last year in el paso and the el
paso deputy d.a was with us and it was a
the murder suspect was from el paso he
had committed the murder in el paso
ran back to juarez i said remember they
said i don't remember i don't remember
he said remember we have ways of
reminding you oh
and then he tells he looks at that one
detective he looks at one detective just
gives him the nod
and saying hello
and so the guy starts walking up
and he says take off his glasses
and the guy whips out his leather belt
starts wrapping it around his
and the homicide cop from el paso nudged
me says that's a guy with the cattle
prod
and he starts coming up and he's about
ready
and the suspect starts saying
hey hey i'm remembering i'm remembering
it's all coming back right now damn and
he says okay and the d.a is ready to
[ __ ] in his pants because he can't be
taking confessions and stuff like that
you know that's
and he says see me according to any the
d agent says hey stop stop him you know
we don't need this stuff right here
we're not here for him that's a totally
separate case and the commandant is okay
he says we'll talk later and then they
take him out and he says in spanish he's
telling me see we have ways over here
man dude that's what it is right that's
what it is with the cattle prod bro like
jesus
which i confess into everything
this is why i stay home i don't do
nothing
i just think well what do you do the
real comic book dude i'm a cop i'm a
movie guy i don't know i just love
watching movies
that's right because i'm terrified i'm
gonna get in trouble doing some [ __ ]
and i'm gonna have to deal with the
cattle prod guy let me tell you we went
to tijuana years and years ago in the
early 80s we're all drinking saturday
afternoon you know the open air thing
and we're sitting in there music's
playing they're doing the whole thing
with a shake your head and this dude
that looks like you know kenny loggers
with a beard long hair takes a [ __ ]
joint i like to join and like that place
was on fire people jumped out of the out
of the
windows because the comandantes when
they [ __ ] blow the whistle they
[ __ ] got that dude they drug him away
and the [ __ ] waiter goes that was the
last time you're going to see that
[ __ ] guy
and they go how come he goes smoking
weed in a [ __ ] place that's why you
see everybody jump out of the windows
because they can be like you and you and
you was like hey [ __ ] that he smoked it
not me
all three of you and they as soon as
they saw that dude because they go in
there and grab you who where was this at
home in tijuana oh
and they're in the early 80s they drug
that dude out of there and everything
went back to normal like five minutes
later and the waitress comes over and
goes you won't see that [ __ ]
around anymore
i go how come he goes because he smoke
weed and tijuana here that's a [ __ ]
like in in in tijuana like that's a
known man that's unknown in a club
in the afternoon don't do it like i
didn't know i don't want to be
repetitive but i told you when we went
to acapulco to bring back two guys from
how they they beat the shadow of those
guys brother they man listen man that's
another country they
that's why
they can pull you over standing in the
middle of the road until you are
speeding you're like
how do you know
give me the money huh [ __ ] give me
the money i did i did a show and now i
did a show at rocky point puerto penasco
and um long story short we never got
paid but um
but that guy wrote me a check and put it
with mom bro when we got back and then
when i got home and bounced
[Laughter]
we drove two hours from
phoenix to
rocky point puerto penasco it was
supposed to be like this big old concert
um coolio was supposed to be the
headliner
and um
we get there dude and um
the promoter from america so he didn't
know the rules in mexico you're gonna
pay everybody
so he had an agreement with the club
that they were gonna stay open and stay
closed while the concert was going on so
it was just a word of mouth they're
gonna stay club but he never like paid
them to stay close
why would they stay close all these kids
coming to america
so this guy's saying uh at the last
minute he said with everybody here free
so that guy couldn't sell tickets for
the his concert no more okay so
everybody's mad a lot of rappers that
are not going to perform so everybody
goes to the clubs so these rapper dudes
are over there at this club and that
fool don't understand what he's doing
man he starts peeing in the club
right next to a plant
and then there's like this paisa walking
around he's like a security guard for
the clubs i guess
he's just a blue suit with a night stick
and a leather wrap to hold it so i'm
going to slip off so it's not like gill
like it won't slip off i was flying
so he's did he start fighting with them
he started fighting with a little dude
because ah little mexican guy i'm a big
black dude whatever but then 10 of them
came out of nowhere man so they're
beating him so then he's still fighting
with him they take him outside
man then i got syria these two um
federalists
came out of a volkswagen same door
and
bro anyways
they took the dude and handcuffs him and
his partner is beating him up in the
back seat with a night stick while he's
driving bro
and that bla the black dude's homies
recording the whole thing
and i told that black dude hey homie
that ain't gonna help here
you know you should just
throw away the tape
sell that camera to the to the captain
and get use that for bail money because
your friend is gonna come out of jail
today they're going to beat the sheriff
more
because he's
he's the resistant arrest you know with
these guys he's i'm american
i have rights the guy said
you know racist [ __ ] dog
wow
and over there it's another country for
you you can argue with a cop who has
pro wings bro
that has what pro wings on bro tennis
shoes
he's a clean-ass car bro
he had never taken a bride but he went
pro wings everybody else wearing dress
shoes
and whatever
bro
yeah so that you know
you don't need up you don't need uh the
proper vehicle to be in charge in
another country no you don't
you don't
i know right i know i see like point
like you see you seen those um
documentary like in poland yeah they
arrest the body and then the cop and uh
the guy he arrests her on the bus going
to jail
oh yeah
that's why i said if i went to jail i
would blow everyone the first come on
line up
[Laughter]
something's [ __ ] crazy come on
you can't go twice everybody come on
you're like [ __ ] yeah
he's [ __ ] crazy
then they leave you alone they go come
over here i'll [ __ ] suck your [ __ ]
right dog
all right that's what that's right
you go to the shower everybody takes off
running come on
you grew up in bakersfield right i grew
up in bakersfield so whenever like
there's a problem with one mexican
family all the police station shows up
huh it's a it's a thing yeah i know my i
have a couple cousins in prison for some
[ __ ] they don't want to go they go
to like the kiosk of the house
they just swing by i remember like my
cousins tell me like yeah they just come
by like they're just be hanging out in
the front yard and they just swing by
and just like start harassing them it's
a thing i remember i read that the
[ __ ]
there was a study that they did i don't
know what was it new york times or some
[ __ ] and like current county
has one of like the most racist
sheriff's department in the nation i'm
like where's in like the south
apparently that's what they said i was
like oh [ __ ] i was like okay there's
another country over there oh it's not
even that far three hours away yeah like
oil
oh yeah well there's oil pumps
everywhere there's you go to the the
parking lots and there's just oil pumps
in the parking lots everywhere it's rich
over there how rich but it doesn't
indicate in the in the in the
neighborhoods though no but it's the
money they're pumping out of there is
rich that's where merle hagger is from
oil dale
right oh i met merle haggard and i said
where you from man it's like you're from
not from i'm from a bigger square of oil
i [ __ ] i said i know where oil dale is
i don't know everybody with buck oil
robin williams and kurt russell was up
there in taft was it buck hogan's or
merle haggard that had his own uh book
coins
yeah he had another place up there he
had everything he had everything he was
big but going
and then our other fame is corn the
banana is up from up there's two corn
yeah and the fox theater and the fox
theater that's badass fox theater mm-hmm
uh it's a it's a fun place it's a
stripper the gold miner the ghostlinger
was it this yeah
i moved away before i could get into
those places
hey so so let's talk about can we talk
about netflix let's talk about it all
right marvin so marvin created uh
identified with linda vichabez say yes
and great i mean great critical acclaim
one of the great actors really presented
you did both see this yeah and he
brought it up from uh from uh it was
another show before that it was it was a
a web series before okay so it's
starting to web series too
yeah it was a digital series that we did
like with macro produced it they
financed it america ferreira was our ep
like her and and and macro
juntos like we did the digital series we
didn't have a home for it
and then like i cut a trailer before i
even cut episodes and we dropped it
online and i got all this attention your
money
we had i mean our budget for the digital
series we did like seven episodes and it
was like 150 grand for the whole series
for the digital series it was like and
which for me at that time was like oh my
god the biggest budget i had worked with
but it was like we had a cast of like 50
different actors and like all these
locations it was wild i should have cut
episodes um
but we got into sundance we premiered
the digital series at sundance and
that's how we ended up that's awesome
you know you guys all went to sunset you
went to sundance no he wasn't in you
weren't in the distance i was in the web
series but i remember meeting with you
yeah we met in um silver lake
yeah but i we were i was because i was
trying to cast him as one of the
the characters in the digital series but
you were busy while we were you were
like out of town you were gonna be on a
show doing something in uh i don't
remember where but so you weren't
available so i got to
but i always just like when we got the
show on netflix i was like we gotta get
felipe in there like he's like from ball
heights like you're hysterical i'm such
a fan and i was like we got to get him
in there and so we were able to get him
in there as crazy dave so then you went
over there and pitched to netflix like
you had your agent got your meeting and
trying to walk through all those steps
because all the steps all the steps was
this thing
or some of the steps you know
i'll give the the broad strokes of it i
mean even before we got into sundance we
had started working we were getting all
this tv attention we wanted to make a
digital series just to put it like see
if we could find a home for it right but
the tv conversation started very quickly
we worked on a pitch for like five
months and then we in that time got into
sundance we premiered it at sundance and
like literally we got back from sundance
and immediately started pitching it all
over the town we had like seven offers
from like the top tier networks like
[ __ ] fx and showtime and
all hbo all the places but netflix
always felt like the home for it
because i wanted my like i was he's like
oh you know i love hbo pedo i want my
cousins to be able to watch him back in
bakersfield the festivals have
somebody's password on netflix though or
have to stay into a hotel
and that was like after we had sold it
this is like
and that was like a year later that of
developing it we finally got the green
light and we started shooting it but do
do they does netflix only do two seasons
now it feels like it i mean yeah they
went from almost being like a home i
mean they even canceled like ozark and
those are that got cancelled it did damn
i didn't know after this this season's
to drop and that's it no i see there's a
rare
three or four but i mean you ever seen
it no it's a [ __ ] you'll love it oh
it's great yeah it's i've heard it's
i've heard it's amazing i mean they
heard it has breaking bad and the movies
that come out now the movies that so
they'll run amc has breaking bad over
the now it's on netflix and all the
seasons are there so if they
pick it up but before it seemed like
when they picked up a series that they
would commit to the series and let the
series be its
run its course yeah like when though
when it was like the first theory i
remember like they give you mass
advertisement on buses
then the second season you gotta pass
out flyers
they give you four teams they give you
four episodes first they're like oh
we're gonna get another four another six
now we'll give you another four we're
gonna keep your limb away for about five
months now what the [ __ ] is that how
they did it
i mean i feel like at that beginning so
the executive over there they saw the
first season everybody yeah people by
surprise yeah man i mean that first
season was i mean we came out the gate
like they gave you know there was a lot
of support for it we do the top ten and
we dude we came out we when we launched
the series like two days later is when
the top 10 feature came out i remember
one in the morning it was right there it
was like like it was we hope we dropped
on a friday and then it was like sunday
or monday the top and i was like i
remember opening netflix and i was like
what is this good week right good two
weeks maybe what's that it went from
like nine eight seven and ten ten it
just stood up there no i remember it was
like like okay we dropped on a friday
and then on sunday or monday the top ten
features showed up on netflix and we
were at number three or number four
and i was like what the [ __ ] is this i
was like top ten and i was like wait
what like top ten so caught you by
surprise that's all we had well it was a
brand new thing and they didn't announce
that they were gonna do this topic they
were not doing that before yeah it was
brand new you know who was number one on
uh netflix
outdoor right here
he was number one last night stalker
you know how hard it is to be number one
on netflix for a week in the hours
it's not even like after the show's
felipe you're not even out of the club
partying or they're taking your name
down you know your heart is to be up
there on netflix but it changes by the
hour man like don't look up and there's
something you know the queens gambit or
something like that again
in the world they in the world
number one in the world let me tell you
one in the nation number six in the
world can i tell you i i i rock your
point up there
i didn't watch the document the show
because i watched a trailer and it
terrified me that i didn't want to watch
the whole thing
i was just like i'm not going to watch
it they grew up with their philippines
don't worry about your kids man you know
your kids are in a good place i really
like that kevin are you drinking all the
milk mensa
felipe council you know your kids hey
listen you know a lot a lot of parents
hate their kids don't beat yourself up
misunderstood [ __ ] cuckoo he's like
hey listen
right here don't judge me by what you
[ __ ] know already hey that's a
[ __ ] hey man you know what has
respect they
you do not like that no more
hey she's got a whole other bunch of
kids she loves
all right so then it goes over there and
then you see it trending which is big
for everybody i remember that yeah man
it was crazy it was crazy to see that i
mean um i mean yeah man it was great it
was weird and then it was like about i
don't know about a month a month and a
half before we found out uh because they
like to wait and they love to see their
first month they don't have upfronts or
anything right so so
is when you you're part of a network or
wherever the upfront is they take the
actors to new york and you you know see
all the shows and all the actors yeah
and it's all the advertisers over there
so but they don't do because they don't
have ads it's all subscription based
right so that's that's the that's right
i think there's a is it new fronts or
maybe that's the digital the short form
[ __ ] anyways um
so yeah man i mean a month a month and a
half later we got the pickup for season
two and
and then
and then we started writing it took a
little while before we like could start
because like oh because the pandemic
started like two three weeks after we
launched the show so there was like a
while where they're like okay we're
gonna do this but we also don't know
nobody's shooting everything's locked
down
um
so there was a big delay before you know
linda and i could start working on the
second season but um but yeah and then
but we got the eight episodes instead of
the 10 for the second season
and we had which is why which is why
they which is because what why because
i think there was
there was some but they do it to
everybody don't they they do it i think
there was you know one they told us the
numbers like they were good but they
weren't as great as they wanted and
we're like that's fine they're like so
we're gonna you know we'd like to and we
asked for a couple things that were like
yo we gotta have these things if we can
move forward for season two so the way
that they did it was by cutting two
episodes
um
did we get to see any of those savings
not necessarily but
we did the eight and we're like fine
that's fine we're gonna do these eight
episodes and especially i mean with the
covet of it all um i don't know we like
shot like right after like what was it
like january of 21. so like right after
like everybody went into production at
the same time it was like kind of safe
to start going back into shooting and um
this is before like right as the vaccine
was starting to get rolled out for like
those first groups like you know seniors
were getting it um
it was a wild time to be shooting but
yeah man so we did those eight it was uh
i remember they were they gave us um
these
these little chips on the set yeah to
follow you around the weekend or after
the show to see to track your ftc if you
caught it then they'll kind of locate
where you caught it
well it was just on set though
if you took it off and that was on you
got to return it
they could track who you were close to
oh my god so that in case like you got
it they would know who did you come near
and that way they could make sure that
they got tested in quarantine would they
have those in jail or what were they i
don't know i wasn't with them though i
swear to god the only way you care about
that
i never heard of this home depot
lowe's for sure because you are testing
everybody in a scent every day every
week no three times a week three times a
week we were testing um
did the cast and i think the cast might
have gotten tested a little bit more
than that because they were the ones
that have their masks off you know most
of the time so
yeah
um i mean i heard about other shows that
they were doing testing every day yeah i
was on superstore i was testing every
day yeah and then when i was out of town
they paid me to stay in town really i
got paid more to stay home than i did to
work on the show
that makes sense yeah i mean they got
testing every day money on that actually
yeah yeah
but so so so where they were good
partners all right because i mean and
it's still on there even though it's the
two seasons it's going to be on there
forever yeah i mean we just got i mean
so we got we got the news last month
that we were getting cancelled for this
though they would be the end of the road
linda what would they give it to who do
they who are all of it to me linda the
president
i don't know we had a big meeting of the
with all the zoomer and it was a zoom
pero i wasn't even on it i was i was
shooting an episode i was directing an
episode of a show and so i couldn't be
on it i had to get like after i wrapped
i called linda i'm like what happened
like what's up and she's like we got
cancelled um
and i was so busy with the with the
episode i was directing i was like okay
got it all right cool well all right
well i'll talk to you later and i just
like didn't think about it for a couple
weeks because i was so busy right it
just didn't hit me but
yeah man that's how it went down but
then it publicly got announced this past
week on my [ __ ] birthday oh no
haven't got leaked well happy birthday
it was a rough day uh but it was like it
was leaked apparently it wasn't supposed
to be announced yet and then they got
leaked somehow and they
they gave us like 20 minutes notice that
they were going to be dropping the news
and oh so so you were still shooting it
was not supposed to be out while you're
still [ __ ] shooting no well no this
was i was shooting this was like
december last week
this was uh last week they
netflix all of a sudden calls me they're
like we just got word
somebody a deadline they got a source
and they they got the the news that
we've been they that the show's
cancelled and they're about to drop it
um like and they're like have you called
everybody and we're like we haven't
caught some of the cast yet like we're
still barely starting to tell people so
it was a bit of a rough day trying to
like
handle all that nonsense did you think
that it was going to go on as you know
when you when you started to do the
second season did it
feel to you like it had legs to go right
would it have gone three and 40 yeah of
course right you know
linda and i went into it
if you watch the show in the season the
way it ends
linda and i were like you know we don't
know we don't know if there's another
season
we
i'll say i was like i don't think
netflix wants to do another season of
this i didn't feel that energy i was
like i get the sense that this is the
end of the road and so we ended it the
way that we ended it so that we would
have an ending because but we knew i was
like there's we know where our third
season would go we knew you know that it
ends with you know being able to see pop
and chris in mexico and we're like we'll
do like a few episodes in mexico we'll
do like you know we'll be able to see
the whole family out there that would be
so much fun if we could do that um but
we also ended it we're like if this is
it then then it has like a closed end
right good that's good so you know we
got to have our cake you know a little
bit with that um
and you think that should be
consideration for like a show with
latinos on there or
you is it all just part of a a big
machine that it doesn't matter what what
color you know you say you if you say
there you need faces you know of all
different colors on on
streaming
and then you know do they take into
consideration that you know
i go
another season
i mean the money's not not the issue
yeah obviously no i mean
i think
i mean they do they have so much they're
doing so much
it is unfortunate
they do things so different from other
networks right like
yeah they have their algorithm i mean
even if you look back at queen's gambit
queen's gamut didn't have huge marketing
until after it came out and all of a
sudden in that first week it took off
and then that's when you start to see
all the marketing for it and that's kind
of the way that they do things they're
like
they throw it out and see like is this
it feels like this like they throw it
down they're like does it work is it
hitting and if it's hitting that's when
they start to like you know really do
push do you think when they when they
have it on their own netflix like when
they do come upcoming i think they do
promos right
on netflix and you and they put that up
there is that big because as big as
netflix is that that that even promotion
on its own when you open the home page
it's one of the promos that you're gonna
look for that now yeah
upcoming like there's a there's a side
thing on the side where it says search
then i then it says
blah then they say the upcoming shows
you really got to search for it unless
you're watching news shows all the time
against the algorithm but what about you
the netflix thing it goes to a home page
right yeah yeah it stops at whatever
shows number one i think
yeah well i think that's what the top 10
is it because everybody's going to be
the best your home page is different for
everybody like everybody's like
different like it's it's following what
you're watching
out there you're not going to see the
fight come on you know like maybe if
you've watched it before but you're
gonna see the
the tiger king whatever
right and so of course like yeah it's
like it's they have their whole
algorithm that i think you know that
they really lean on
um
but you know whatever the man
i mean it could change [ __ ] yeah in a
day
in a week you know so i mean my big
thing is i'm like well an algorithm like
you know an algorithm is not like
faultless an algorithm's made by a
person and i'm like these things have
been proven to have bias that's what you
know i mean did you find out him
what's on your homepage pornography
coming soon
vegan porn actresses yeah it is they
don't eat meat
vegan strip bars
vegan strip bars there's actually one in
portland bro no meats i see it i can i
can totally see that yeah no curtains i
heard
[Laughter]
well the first thing that shows up
january 19 that that um argentinian show
they had the season four
the what what is this marginal
i've never heard of this yeah
yeah marginal is a show that was the
biggest show ever in argentina history
and i'm netflix bought it already
already made
and then that's not netflix show but
that show is was off the air four years
ago on argentina but then they had like
a resurgence on netflix it became like
it was like kind of a top ten oh so they
just put it up they just bought it they
bought it with they bought like um 30
episodes so now they're so big that
their netflix was forced to do it i'll
see them for now they're gonna have to
start paying for yeah production and
stuff yeah yeah so now they gave them
netflix gave them a budget
but
i don't they're not gonna have to see
them six they know what i mean no
kenzavi i don't know i don't know i mean
it doesn't feel like i don't think
what's the last thing that they did that
had that many seasons i don't know uh
house of cards yeah
and uh was that the last thing that had
happened um
yeah that would have been yeah we're not
wearing black yeah when was your new
black and how the car got canceled i saw
the end of anything come going the past
three years because the new car yeah uh
orange and you black is was a was like
huge man seven seasons seven seasons
that's like unheard of now yeah
absolutely that would never yeah
the holidays went by quickly do you
remember to take care of your package
with the best tools for the job the
performance package 4-0 from manscape is
just the thing every guy needs in their
life to take each and every day just a
little more special the number one
product in this package is the lawnmower
4.0
this electric trimmer is designed to
trim hair on loose skin
and get this
the trimmer skin advance skin safe
technology reduces cuts and nicks
on your delicate balls
it even has 4 000 led spotlight so you
can shave anywhere your heart desires
did i mention
that it's waterproof too
i'd like to propose
making february 13th a national holiday
as national shaver balls day who's with
me
who's with me
i think this is one holiday the men and
women can get behind
this package also includes the weed
whacker nose and hair trimmer to whack
all the worst of your weeds manscaped
even threw in the two free gifts
their shed travel bag
and anti-chafing boxer briefs to keep
your boys stored comfortably get 20 off
and free shipping with the code omg hi
at manscape.com that's 20 off
free shipping at manscape.com use the
code
omghi
join cupid and shoot your arrow ho hoi
with manscaped happy valentine's day
and get ready for a pelo paso at night
skin on skin
i don't know i don't mean it seems like
it it doesn't it definitely feels good
but it's so crazy because it's somewhere
else what about when uh one day at a
time
forcing them can handify go somewhere
else yeah
it could it could be
i i you know i know gloria and i know
that like that was like a big effort
like she was really trying to keep it
going and trying to find a new home for
it and
i mean robert rodriguez has his own
network
that's right that's true he would have
to be vampire
if if somebody comes to us and they want
to do another season of it on another
network i'd be supe super open to
talking about it but i
i don't want to go out i'm not
that's not why we brought it up but no
you have no but i mean that's just uh
that's where i'm at
you know one day at a time they fought
for did you watch one day at a time on
netflix no
no i mean george lopez in the middle of
the night i watch lopez the the uh
listen when they cancel one day at a
time which is already a remake they
fought hard dude real hard yeah i mean
overly hard
you know my show
well by the time this air is small no
it's gone the 20th year anniversary has
never been up there but to me but to me
when you when you see a show and they're
fighting that hard for that show
i mean hard right i mean
hard on social media
huge campaign i thought what where's
that effort for him to fight like where
where where is that well she had a
really diehard fan base for that and and
i think and gloria really i think she
spirited that i feel like she like
really helped make like you know push
that movement of like you know save the
show because she really
you know wanted to keep going with it
and had more story to tell and i think
linda and i are both kind of we did the
show you know this i feel we i feel
ungrateful when i say this but this is
just how it is the show i did i did the
digital series and for me it was a
calling card and i was like yo this is
great about directing i'm gonna after
this i'm gonna get a feature going like
i want this to be the thing that helps
me get a feature and then all this tv
conversation starting we're like all
right all these doors open and we like
walk through them and so it's been my
life for six years like it feels like a
third season that i did because it
wasn't it was the two seasons of the
netflix show plus the digital series
that i worked on for like a year and a
half before that um but lynn and i are
both like we're like yo like i think
we're i think we're done telling the
story i think we're ready to move on to
the next one and so but don't have that
fire but in no way but in no way
in no way because you know sometimes
they think that shows have to go forever
to be a success but in no way don't ever
look at that like it wasn't in [ __ ]
an incredible achievement no i thought
you laid something down but take it from
me i mean 20 years bro yeah
how many seasons did you guys do we did
120 shows 120 shows jesus and no show
had gone past
four or five i think so it was it was
big for me that was amazing i was in
there all you know i was all more
episode than gilligan's island no for
real 90. oh [ __ ] so it's 20 years still
on it's on all the time it was
nickelodeon with a huge big and then now
it's not in spanish too and espanol
which is
it's like when you see coco in spanish
you know the pixar coco i remember
thinking i was like this is actually a
little bit
that our show is better in spanish
his cubans father-in-law
they're sober but he's picking too fast
that's what that was so funny about
that the scripture writing what the [ __ ]
did he say i said hey don't say anything
to him
leave him alone
it's like danny troyer used to say words
like rodney luther king
he would go the reverend rodney luther
king and they would and the scripture i
would say
don't say anything to him i just let him
because that's part of the whole thing
about when you get old you start to say
[ __ ]
wrong
yeah time i was ten and all going to add
anvils my grandmother goes you bring me
an anvil george's anvil
and anvil the thing no parallel
advil come on [ __ ] it that's what i said
anvil
[Laughter]
but but uh you know so so on to the on
to the next man you know yeah man i'm
excited i mean we got a project going on
together then hopefully you know we'll
be right back
he was amazing too like in superstar and
all the stuff he does bro i told him i
told him this story when i first we were
like i already knew
his comedy was like he has to be in the
show
but i knew i needed to send something to
the network when we were doing the first
season and so i was like oh i need to
get his tape and so they sent me your
tape of like you know the stuff you've
done on superstore and other things and
that scene that you had did i don't
remember what season of super story was
but there was just a scene it was under
the first episode you did with
superstore we'll put it in there we're
gonna put it in and it was just i
watched it like on loop i tell you i was
in my office and and i watched it on
loop like 40 times and it did not stop
getting funny like it was so funny which
one is definitely you were in it for
like a few seconds but it was it was
like like it was like two different
scenes the drug test the drug test it
was that it was that and you're just
like uh over over there like i
self-taped that one that [ __ ] man it was
it was um we're gonna be testing for
marijuana pcb and i'm gonna back like
this is counting everything i was on my
pcb
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i don't know man it just it killed me i
like tickled me so hard so i was just i
loved it and that's the one i was just
like this is the guy he's got to be
crazy quit my job in a warehouse job to
do comedy no [ __ ] now i play a warehouse
guy on tv
there you go
well you you won last comic standing
right yeah so so what in in winning lost
uh last comment
what's the benefits of that how much oh
they give you 250 000 dollars
and uh
which the next day my son mom fought for
child support no lie she became the last
baby mama standing
homie everything so uh
um then they give you like a
85 city tour so that's extra money oh
[ __ ] and you you tour 85 stadium with a
top five then you get a holding deal
with nbc wow you get one meeting bro
one minute prepare for everybody 20
meetings it's going to be a waste of
meeting bro yeah dude
i feel like i'm just barely so that's
almost like like uh they throw it in
there yeah throw it in there i had a
meeting with um
i think lena no she's the abc linda
barbary i don't know the main people of
nbc back then i think it's and then um
we talked about what it was just talked
and they said oh yeah he'd be good for
this but that one they didn't put me on
[ __ ] dude
they just held me for a year
and then i i read for a pilot for a box
that i'm pretty good for but this is my
deal with nbc nah they couldn't oh they
said no yeah
wow wow and you know yeah and they
couldn't let you go i mean
that's not coming back the holding deal
for a year it's like yeah let him do it
if he gets a gig he gets a gig
but not to not to screw somebody up
because every time he's in town locally
i go see him i've been watching him for
years yeah you know he's funny
and how was the tour you already did it
the 85 city tour we did the 85 city tour
all over um um america i guess nbc mills
entertainment all the little theaters
man we went to a lot of places was it
good for you it was good
i saw a lot of people man there's a lot
of fans there but there's a lot of a lot
of older white people who voted
i was in like now places i only heard in
songs bro
allentown pennsylvania bro
billy joe
where
allentown
but they're shutting down the factory
bro that's like the poorest white people
number one with their dog
and um
that place there was all white people
they had they made sweat t-shirts they
had team felipe these old ass people bro
still workers wow and um
in there then i went to one like this
one
picture okay they went to another place
in the same area called fog bro it's
where um
there's a statue of larry holmes there
eastern pennsylvania yeah it's east yeah
he was the eastern assassin larry holmes
was the eastern assassin yeah the the
baseball bats i think yes the baseball
the aluminum bats the best bats ever oh
is it sponsored by easton i mean
you know i remember the next days i used
to play growing up
so we went there
michigan
flint michigan yeah
and flint michigan is as gotcha as they
say oh man that's bad dude you're good
yeah it's unfortunate they're still
dealing with that [ __ ] right luckily
they're they're growing a lot of
marijuana now because of marijuana
michigan okay so they're like making a
lot of money then i went to traverse
city as soon as i got off the bus there
was a medicinal shop
right across the street bro and then i
went there traverse city is like san
francisco you know but with less no
trash um
san francisco with no trash yeah which
place is this traverse city okay
traverse city michigan man
then finally you know when we finally
hit like the latino areas
it was over man for the white comedians
bro
when we hit corporates bro corpus
christi
starting ovation going up the innovation
getting off bro
one line for meeting greets and those
guys have to put away all their cds bro
wow nobody want to buy that [ __ ] damn
that's right happening in a lot of those
places is that sure that show's not out
anymore right hell no they're like no no
they wouldn't see then um
rodman was the last person who win oh
yeah yeah
but then they stopped it bro but um but
how crazy it was they do a background
check on every contestant on last comic
standing like i didn't know about this
so they called me back
i looked at gear like he was in charge
but um
they're coming back nbc lawyers
they said felipe you've been arrested
and for me being arrested means that you
went according through you're in jail
that's being arrested if you got
released the next day you're not
arrested rather than go how does it
count you never could ever be convicted
to me being arrested is being convicted
of a crime when does he arrest what is
is it like when you when the egg meets
the you know the sperm meets the egg is
that
is that
is that one thing you'll rest or the
chill come first
so can you can you if you've never did
time what is it can you be considered
arrested
yeah an arrest is an arrest when does
the arrest start
the [ __ ] handcuffs on you and you go
in and they fill out a book and slip
it's in the computer okay then yeah so
yeah i told the guy
i told him yeah but that was like a long
time ago that was 90.
he was no you got arrested like five
months ago and then he got arrested
again eight months ago a year ago i said
that ain't me man
that ain't me
somebody my family stole my identity
a long time ago think of my brother uh
my brother and then then they went to go
look it up i had to go find a photo of
my brother my brother like a hard
criminal bro no facebook no mice pain no
yahoo messenger never touched a computer
in life wow unless to grab a credit card
you know but um
this fool i found a photo of him
holding my his grandson
and um his granddaughter and i send it
to nbc and he finally cleared it it
wasn't me
wow
that's wild
that's so crazy though because you say
that i'm like oh i have my i just like
over the holidays talk to my my little
cousin who's in prison he was on his
phone on facetime when i was just like i
was like what the [ __ ] how'd you do this
he's like yo we have our ways and i'm
like no [ __ ]
so wild i hadn't seen his face in like
years that [ __ ] was wild so yeah he's
got a mice or a facebook
facebook presence
when i was like
i was in orange county with another
comedian who was in prison for three
years but then he got out george perez
and he told me i met a friend of his
from orange county he goes hey
congratulations you won
i voted for you thank you man thank you
i was in prison in norco when i voted
for you
wow
yeah man everybody myself man we were
watching your show and we were going
around the prison telling everybody
telling all the guards that's we're
telling them vote for number four
they were saying we last brought four
vote for four
[ __ ] alert
that's right [ __ ] dude
god damn it's like that everywhere it
wasn't just like that in the in
you know detention centers everywhere
everywhere man i knew a guy
a guy from sacramento he worked for the
davis county fire station
i'm blas
cain lopez cousin
how that fool said that he got in
trouble because he got on the phones and
he and he sent a mass email bro like oh
with the phone number of last comic
standing and to vote for me oh to other
clients yeah yeah
that's awesome that's awesome
that's amazing and you're doing that
show you're with the the netflix show
coming up yeah then the the festival
netflix is the joke yes at the orpheum
at the orpheum that's april 29 yes hell
yeah dude orphan is great i've been in
an orpheum it's awesome
i used to go there with the movie
theater bro
jaws there i think or star wars i don't
know i should go there to watch uh close
circuit wrestling
there she is
there's a battle royal from like new
york
what's that the mayan is that what it is
yeah
it's the orpheum or the state of los
angeles the one that
you go upstairs and there's like a nice
little baby lounge
and then you go into the bathroom and
it's another lounge for men and another
loving lounge for women and there's like
a mutual lounge back in the day when you
smoke cigarettes
i think it's a state
oh yeah i think so yeah man
i know some great old old theaters all
that i mean imagine how many used to be
in downtown l.a and then there's hardly
any now
yeah
the when we first premiered the digital
series like so when we went to sundance
we only we were sharing it was like you
know it's a film festival so we shared
the block with a few other web series
and we only did like three episodes but
then they that sundance that year did um
in la they called it next fest and they
like brought some of the projects that
are like
that are about la in some way yeah and
so of course they asked us to do a
screening of the full web series it was
the first time the only time that i ever
screened the whole web series and it was
at the the ace theater downtown oh yeah
east across the street man and that
theater and like it was like almost
packed i heard there was like standing
room upstairs i'm like oh on the balcony
to see that [ __ ] like
on that
they got a big old screen in there and
it was a huge theater and that [ __ ] was
yeah man that theater is nice yeah that
so that theater has a special place in
my heart yeah all those downtown spots
are sick yeah the horror film is good
man that's awesome that'd be great
you'll love it down there that's gonna
be sick have you been have you played
there before never oh man just snuck in
yeah that's good man i need to go to
cant the clifton next door clifton
clifton
yeah
as a kid
yeah my lady she talks about it too so
when they were reopening she said we
gotta go check it out and she's like i
mean we used to go all the time when we
were kids and she's like yeah it's like
a whole bro different now when i was a
little kid my brother took a massive
[ __ ] himself right he was like three or
four
and my mom lost my mom lost
[Applause]
my mom spanked him bro she got all
messed with splattered on his back
bro she [ __ ] like i think she took
her to the bathroom and brought her back
to our seat naked
no just a little shirt and she said he
can't stay comfortable this that [ __ ]
went all mad for blueberries bro to buy
clothes
because they were jungle boy bro oh my
god that's so wild
oh jeez that was stupid in his past
probably
[Laughter]
she didn't take him with her to the
start she was sick
[ __ ] gummy before i [ __ ] started
this show
that [ __ ] hit me right there with that
thing goddamn man that's so [ __ ]
funny man it was just a [ __ ] little
towel
my dog my daughter [ __ ] in the park and
we went to the park
and they go grab every [ __ ] napkin
that came back it's like all over how
the [ __ ] did it get up her back
man got that heroin [ __ ]
different but you know when you have
kids now you know everybody has a
[ __ ] wipe and they have all the red
shirts you're ready man
awesome you have a kid or you've been
driving you're like what the [ __ ] you've
got guy your [ __ ] hand
your [ __ ] fingernail you know you're
like
you got a kid this [ __ ] gets every it's
[ __ ] everywhere everywhere man it's
like where's the more dogs they said
there's somebody next to you [ __ ]
themselves
everywhere
like a crime scene just [ __ ] everywhere
oh [ __ ] and you need the wives before
before they had uh
i'm not getting the the disposable wife
you have to just go get
like three or four thousand whatever
yeah i wear them
you're gonna grab that towel with the
towel and bring it down and wipe it and
bring it down
i mean you know whoever invented all
that [ __ ] with it with this white sizing
wipes it's all just going to the thing
getting four napkins and weddings
we should have these when they come out
nobody used those things before
i know there were no wives who know with
a kid man
no
put him on the same thing i didn't [ __ ]
when i was a kid i was afraid
i had i don't know
i was terrified of going to [ __ ] at
school growing up in public school yeah
because i went when i was in like the
first grade maybe the second grade i
went to the bathroom i'm going number
two at the bathroom and then i'm there
i'm [ __ ] pooping right in the school
it's in the school and then all of a
sudden i look up and there's these three
kids looking down looking down on me
over the stall and i was like what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] and i was just like
and they're just like ah they're
pointing and laughing at me and i'm like
yeah dude i'm [ __ ] and after that
dude never never again i would hold that
[ __ ] all [ __ ] day i've i have mad i'm
sure that's where most of my digestive
number two come from from holding it off
i remember like looking down at kids
like that what are you doing
but why would you do that i don't
understand it why would you want to
watch your kid taking a [ __ ]
pacquiao i don't get it
and those were some high-ass doors too
man you could have just looked more yeah
man they were like those [ __ ]
they had like that good upper body
sleeping
let me see [ __ ] shielding is that the
kids knew man it's sloppy joe wednesday
bro let's go to the bathroom and wait
but you know but it's like
you would have knocked that
[ __ ] you're there a long time like seven
hours
you have sloppy joe after after you know
sloppy joe day those burritos
jumping around your stomach flowing
i remember i would walk home there were
days i would walk home from school
and it was one of those you know those
walks where you're just like i gotta get
home right now because i've been holding
it for [ __ ] six hours and then you
just like there were so many times man
you just got to stop and you just stand
there for a while because you're just
like i can't if i take another step
mecago
no just me all right no no no no no no
yeah
i love it when i was in high school man
you know you take some [ __ ] correct
all you know you got [ __ ] high school
you got to lose some weight you know for
baseball [ __ ] around and take correct
off i was taking correct i was running i
was going home i was like i'm not going
to make it inside so so my grandfather
had these two
patches of grab the grass was his like
you know his [ __ ] pride and joy and
it was already dark so i pulled right
down
but like
a hor a little horse would would [ __ ]
not like a regular person
like a little beat look almost like a
beehive like i shared a beehive and then
my grandfather the next day he's like
he [ __ ] blamed it on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] great game halfway down the
street
i'm trying to bring your [ __ ] dollar
so if
[ __ ] right here
i don't know some people could [ __ ] in
water man i can't what like [ __ ] when
they're swimming oh yeah oh my god my
brother fernando man we were in mexico
we're at espresso [ __ ] damn in
sinaloa we're swimming and then my dad
seen his [ __ ] big old log passing by
and my brothers he's [ __ ] back
stroking [ __ ]
oh was terrible [ __ ] drones in the
[ __ ] water i would always jump out of
the water go to a bathroom
yeah
no
any normal people can't you can't [ __ ]
in the water man
piss my brother's gay though you know
no i don't think so i never [ __ ] in the
water man like you know that's a whole
caddyshack that whole movie was about
dude
it was a baby room
and oh yeah
everybody you know jumped duty
nobody else number two they yelled that
they held duty
no i'm not gonna say it do you have a
convict throw [ __ ] at you
no yeah i did yeah i did dude
didn't make it
either neither did he convict right oh i
know but don't don't they do that like
you walk by they'll piss at you and all
that stuff just want attention now yeah
they get it too yeah but they do that
right they can and what's the penalty
for that like you walk by a cell you
throw a cup of piss out at an opposite
assault what is that on the
when does life begin
saw with a smiley weapon i saw some
[ __ ] meows
[Laughter]
it depends if you're talking short
short-term or long-term penalty
oh my god
man where'd you go where'd you go grant
the bathroom
alcohol
you do your podcast here huh yeah we
used to do it here
during that pandemic we stopped coming
here how long have you been doing your
part you're one of the first dudes that
i was doing we started in 2015
right yes
something like that yeah yeah i did one
of the first shows yeah you were on our
top you were episode seven i think or
eight didn't they go to your house you
said yeah yeah here's a county ali ali
county sheriff emblem
swim pool lasd
big la is the 18 inch letters
wow so you can see it from the sky yeah
oh that's dark i didn't know that would
you take a picture and send it and let's
take a look at that yeah yeah let's see
in like in the pool like yeah the floor
of the pool yeah most people put [ __ ]
playboy bunnies and then [ __ ]
i told him to do it he says we can't do
that what if you sell the house i said
so what
he said well it's it's going to be there
i said okay so he says what happens if
it's a bad guy i said well it's a bad
guy he'll know that it's centrally held
he shares the apartment
he'll know that the helicopter up in the
sheriff's department they'll think he's
a friendly you know what i got him
a yellow
tile that says staff service on the back
and black you know what about those are
where they have the [ __ ] wind breaks
staff patrol whoever that guy owned my
house and your diving board made of a
sap right yeah
we did the we did the first one that's
pretty good in my backyard sheriff
emblem in his pool
and then uh we did it we did another one
last year i think
and that one wasn't that one was a zoom
and i
you you don't know this but you asked uh
your lovely wife was taking the calls
and they wanted to see my socks yeah
somebody after somebody sock checked you
on that podcast so he says hey they want
to know yeah they want to i said how
high are your socks they come around my
cab and he says real oh they want to see
so i said okay no problem so i lifted up
my paneling and i'm tilting the
uh
yeah
and i can hear from the bedroom my
wife's screaming
oh my god he's showing his legs
screaming they couldn't hear but i could
hear him i just started laughing and
showed my legs and then his his comment
was well there you go the higher the
sock the downer the dude dude that's
right
he's true he's right that's right
so so what uh go ahead what's the
highest i see some cholo with some high
ass socks so but not above the knees nah
man just like just to the [ __ ]
cartilage just enough to look like pee
wee reese from the dodgers yeah yeah
yeah right above to the let's see what
do you got that's pretty high
mine aren't that high i know are you
they're like i mean i'm mad like i'm out
of the hood but i was there at one time
oh yeah
[Music]
look at that wonder woman
wonderful
wonderful it was uh
it's fun this guy
like you
this guy makes me laugh you've been
doing a long time wherever he goes
wherever i'm at they'll hear me they'll
yeah where did you start how did you
what year did you start we've known each
other a long time i started like the
first time ever ever performing on stage
was in like in late of 94 at the
at the uh only the place called um
the natural fudge oh on silver lake it's
a theater i know i did it and i met um
alonzo bowden there well let me let me
see masada hello jamie kennedy felipe
and alonzo bowden both funny men
both have won last comic standing
both
have done comedy for the guys from
homicide at
steven statehouse thank you
america
both
i remember we did an irish show
and um it was it was funny michael that
was for the um the commerce city of
commerce rotary club
and um
they still cover rotary club and it was
all st patrick's day likes real st
patrick they had hula singer hula
dancers they had a whole thing okay
for st
and um they had nothing but irish food
la rasa was not ready for that they were
already born they're not ready for no
corn beef no oh man it was all irish
food it was like corned beef what is
that like steamed cabbage steamed
cabbage yeah potatoes red cabbage
and it was all rasa bro and there was
some white people there man who were
like irish
but i guess all they have is red hair
but uh
he does theme nights over there that was
a team night for st patrick's day oh
i used to put on
a fundraiser for the national latino
peace officers association for the
homicide bureau
and i would put three four hundred
people in there
uh just for fundraising do you mind wow
easy
i remember going there my other waitress
were all right
now they were
yeah
if you're into women
yeah wednesday wednesday they have
pictures there for old ass people there
man like tommy lasorda when he had hair
tommy lasagna
yeah muhammad ali
yeah
how long has it been there it's been
there since the
50s i believe
that the victor state house right never
been there pictures victor's right there
by alhambra
no i ain't never that steve steak house
i don't know
no stevens after five after five there
was one over there off caddy's uh what
this guy had a room there also
and it was another state house and i
think the
one of the the other half of the solid
brother you to perform there oh yeah
rudy and stevie and then the specter had
a place up in alhambra
though spectre yeah
it wasn't the quiet cannon no
or the hot baby or the hop that's where
i see you man
i actually see your name all the time
there like performing there my friend uh
my co-host rodrigo snook in to see your
show
yeah [ __ ] that was the days man
man i never i'll never forget performing
there man it was
yeah i would have my bootleg cds
i remember i saw 26 of them i'm like
[ __ ] i made more money off
i only seen you perform once george
it was at the robobank arena in
bakersfield
and it was um i mean [ __ ] i was like in
the nosebleeds
and then there was a fight some cholo
started fighting and i thought the whole
show was gonna stop but it didn't i
don't even know if you noticed it but
they just started fighting in the
section
security comes and kicks them out and i
was like keep going yeah i just thought
it was the most badass thing i was like
oh if he noticed it he didn't give a
[ __ ] yeah me
i saw you
on um
five o'clock funnies the first time oh
yeah with um
benson
oh yeah mitchellini had a room at um oh
oh something
or carlos yeah yeah yeah yeah oh but
first time i saw it was on uh on on four
o'clock funnies and then when you hosted
que locos right i was there like doing
warmer goddamn hilarious and then um
when you did your um i don't know if you
were showcasing at the lab factory for
sandra bullock for your show [ __ ] bro
that was like the best [ __ ] set i've
seen in my [ __ ] life to this day only
like you know you'll remember the good
ones i saw chappelle do a hour it was
awesome but yours i remember man i was
in a bag with all the cheerleaders you
know like the young me and the other
fools young comics and um sandra was
there
everybody was there and i remember like
the the older comics like you you don't
know you know you think that i'm all i
can see george so maybe i'll go up after
him they'll see me too but hell no man
half of the audience left they were up
there congratulating you but that was
like the best set i've seen ever like it
was like
pound for pound from the beginning to
end
like non-stop laughs you know like some
people think they killed and they say
like they got mediocre laughs but this
was like bud gusting like like almost
like oh yeah like [ __ ] i'm watching the
show i don't need a drink right now
yeah yeah yeah there you go
wow like
bro like huge fan i'm never gonna be
like this you know what i mean i should
just quit right now
i'm
you got like an hour but you got three
jokes that never work but you still use
them
[ __ ] dude i wish i could have been
around i wish i could have seen some of
those back in the day like [ __ ]
before sometimes because somebody you're
just out there before people know you
you know you're kind of you're kind of
the best you know so
those those were those were good album
but right now right now it's hard to
find what's the other i have a cd card
right right now right now right now that
wasn't that hard to find because they
were later later no right now right now
because that one was uh was that one of
your earliest ones yeah because that was
a drones in one and then george kind of
removed so that was you have that one
it's hard to find yeah draw something
i get the collector's item
[ __ ] he knows
that one another's team leader oh
they're a team leader but that one
that's good too that one got nominated
for a grammy yeah
three grammy nominations and i never
lost to
i never lost a comedian i lost a weird
al because if where that was nominated
he's gonna win and then i lost to fly to
the conchords which is music 2000 i lost
to
in 2009 i lost with stephen colbert for
some producing christmas special i did
not 85 minutes live
wow
that's what i'm saying i got to a
cooking show bro for a reality show you
get which ones
i was nominated for best special for um
i don't know whatever latino award show
is vida or
bo
alma yes
yeah
i lost to the the cooking show for that
lady on pbs
i don't know twice
the cooking show we lost to her
and now it was funny because
how did we lose because of hers is a
variety
variety show live and she we're
competing against her but now they
changed it now stand up is different
that's why um aydah rodriguez got
nominated i don't know she won though
but we don't comedy doesn't compete with
variety shows do they they separate it
in there separate it now that's what it
should be it's so weird that they like
lump you all in in like a different well
they did in the beginning maybe there
wasn't enough artists to cover yeah
buying categories and now they don't you
know that they need to separate yeah i
never lost to a uh
but i mean it would be nice to win but i
mean it's good nominated i can't change
the way that i can't i don't i never
yeah
it's not about getting a is that about
is that it's not about getting arrested
by getting convicted right that's right
you said it
don't count blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah arrested three times
i don't count them you know
i went to canada twice because you may
have been arrested nope got through
next time i went back you ever been
arrested no and then you said you sure
i've never been arrested well right here
instead you arrested 1990 yeah but i was
released
that's a that's a d.a reject though
if you have a neck tattoo
and if you're suspect even if you have a
clean record they might not let you in
really there was a dude i went there to
do more one time and this guy office guy
is in there and i said we're in the room
and he goes what's the matter he goes
man he goes i had a [ __ ] dui
like in 92. oh yeah he goes there and he
goes and i have a company we make a lot
of money
so every year i bring my clients to
canada we go fishing
we go drinking go around goes and it's
my [ __ ] company because and they're
not letting me in like they're gonna fly
me out
they don't let him in
because he had a dui because now we have
to tell his hit the guy that's with them
but you got to still take those guys but
i'm not going to be there because they
didn't let me in it's like [ __ ] what are
they going to think they're [ __ ] over
a dui
yeah yeah i think also uh that that a
rapper chris brown he has to turn around
him his tour his whole bus
merge everything equipment then let him
in oh really whoa
so they must not have good shows out
there
if you get through man if you get
through you're meant to be there so so
also if you see somebody performing in
canada you know that they're meant to be
in canada because that would be like you
can't come in i got in to do the
montreal i did it when 2005.
edmonton brother i did a comedy club
there
and um
i think i i had to get a
a work permit that's right that cost me
the same amount of being there
ching
yeah yeah so you need to work for me
for free so then when i was i was
studying merch it was messing everything
up with my credit card thing because it
was it was trying it was changing
canadian money to american money
well then i realized oh i'm selling this
for less over here
damn
it it is less
yeah wait the dollar over there's weaker
than here yeah you're saying oh oh i
would've did a movie in the last
like six months or so a year and i
bought a guitar it was like fifteen
hundred dollars less
there than if i would have got it over
here no [ __ ] there we going to canada oh
you know what was manufactured at
they're here here you know what's
illegal over there they didn't know i
was walking around with a headache the
drugstore asking everybody for airborne
it's illegal
they don't exist
oh they looked at me like it was crazy
and they kept sending me over there to a
bunch of [ __ ] tees bro
what they're not coming because airborne
has i don't know
they just don't have it out there they
just don't have it maybe it's a
different name
maybe no no no there's nothing like it
over there nothing there's no airborne
we don't got no powder here bro
get out they give you orange juice
because they get all health care so if
you get sick back in hey go over there
not like here
oh no
i stay over here i don't go over there
i go to ride a day
thrifty's i go to rite aid 50's in the
old days
does writers don't have thrifty ice
cream or they're already they still yeah
yes they do they do they do i had to
just get some [ __ ] strawberry those
were the days of the metal
they would they would freeze the metal
on the cylinder and they'd go in there
they put it still got it they're now
selling them
they're selling them now
wait the ice cream or the
they sell their shoes they they sell
them now that's why i want to get in the
water they put it in the water
like that
i used to get three scoops bro
cherry vanilla and almond no [ __ ]
what was yours mine was uh
rocky road pistachio
[Music]
i didn't like mint chocolate blackjack
cherry and mint chocolate
cherry in there yeah
i like rocky road i like pistachio
yeah but i didn't like uh
i don't like mint chip anything with
mint in it the cherry one man a few
people but it was it was badass actually
i still remember you said the cherries
dark cherry you know and they used to
make that ice cream right here uh
in east l.a it was made by carnation
with the thrifty party oh really and the
strawberry had [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah not like a sliver that
[ __ ] could be like oh [ __ ]
there's a whole big ass strawberry in
there
almond fudge
what the [ __ ] is jamoka like a coffee
with almond in it okay coffee chocolate
with almonds it's probably a racist
somewhere
those 31 flavors when you were a kid no
right uh came on afterwards baskin
robbins came out in 1980 huh
when no what was the first it was 31
flavors 31 flavors yeah they had yeah
they had that's when you try like uh
sherbert bro i couldn't afford to go to
thirty
there's a bunch of them there's one in
culver they're they're all over there
there's one
ice cream i think it's started in
portland but they make they have their
set flavors but then every month they
have new flavors and they got like it
they're so i can just tell you during
thanksgiving sometimes they have this
one that they legit use turkey like real
turkey skin in this ice cream and it
sounds gross
it sounds gross or [ __ ] but then you eat
it and it's like they candy it somehow
anyways they do crazy [ __ ] with this ice
cream and it is so [ __ ] good but it's
very pricey and that's why i call it
ice cream no you gotta try it and they
got vegan they got vegan flavors i used
to go to an ice cream place but i don't
know the name of it because i used to
drive um you know of the [ __ ] 405
harbor free harbor uh highway yeah i
will take that [ __ ] all the way to the
end to a to a lighthouse
saint vincent lighthouse it's over there
past san pedro
has all that [ __ ] dog there's like
no blacks and mascaras over there bro
like
when i walk around there bro like the
mexicans that are there are wondering
why i ain't working dog
there's like so many white people there
and that's where i had the cheesecake
pumpkin pie ice cream
remember when they try to make the
potato chips
yeah sure yeah
[ __ ] storm bro they canceled that
everybody that ate those tricks
you think it's like a different yeah
oh yeah remember they were good but look
good
oh dude with olene's
some oil i remember this what was there
that was it the oil was called the
leftover oh olestra olestra yeah that's
chef
greasy stuff greasy dude they were good
they were good
they couldn't do or else they would have
done the ogs with this but they but they
were like a little bit oilier a little
bit saltier like because you know that's
you can't add oil to the once you buy it
yeah but this one said like oh it's
almost like if you added your own oil
and salt to the chips
some people like that bacon fat man i'm
not a big bacon fat guy but no they yeah
we did well how hardcore vegan are you
right now
like i eat any no no nothing nothing
but there's a coffee shop
in um in san francisco it's called um
it's a radio station it's like a bootleg
rotation called cats radio and they
serve coffee there and they add
two spoons of bacon fat in there no
into the coffee yeah but that's good
what yeah they put cream on it and sugar
and then they did like uh like a bacon
coffee
oh my god and it tastes good i don't
know i know i did something i'd try yeah
i tried yeah i tried it that should be a
coffee proper british deal covered in
proper british dishes
i followed that on uh you take the
property properly
proper british dishes take one and bro
these [ __ ] british people were so
[ __ ] poor bro
bro i thought i was [ __ ] poor but i
never been [ __ ] a world war one poor
you know
what [ __ ] dog like this guy he shows up
i know a piece of uh uh [ __ ] uh
a plate
a a saucepan bro
a cooking plate full of mandeca bro from
the night before you know like we put
that [ __ ] in a little cup but it was
still there so that fool warms it up and
adds a slice of bread and puts it on it
and let's let's it gets all with manteca
and pork for the night before flips it
over
and then puts that on between two breads
it needs a sandwich
yeah i would do that proper british
dishes
so he uses the the the
it's like the the meat meat that's the
salami of the sandwich
proper british dishes take one
proper british dishes this is a ticket
tick
the night before and then you get a
little orange bread put it between
another bread
sauce why not why not sauce
i use a bacon manteca or if i don't have
it i always have in my refrigerator
fresh montague you can buy it at the
store still yeah
rex rex you know they they this animal
felt like a man oh right
a brick of breakfast
or the 10 the 10 the red tin
and and they would they would sell that
[ __ ] and that goes my beans gotta have
that for my beans or anything else i
wanna but the bacon grease yes my
grandmother would put in the beans yeah
oh yeah you wrap it in the put in the
potatoes and the beans like i bake the
bacon and then i make my eggs in that
bacon gravy oh yeah
so how did you get started in being a
vegan um i was um anybody in your family
i was low carbon already that dr atkins
low carb that's payload before payload
[Music]
well yeah yeah but i was doing it the
wrong way right i would think hanging
out with the comedians and they were
doing low carb too but nobody saw a
doctor nobody read directions so we're
just eating cheese and meat all week bro
yeah like no vegetables
no water
diet cokes or just a cheat like we're
gonna in and out and get a four by four
with just four pieces of meat and
lettuce dog yeah wow and eat three of
those all day
and that's 12 meats so like so you can
go over there and order a four bowl four
by four because i i'm afraid to do that
protein style yeah protein style that's
what they call four by four with yeah
and then the bun
four by four protein style and they put
everything in a big old lettuce
it's much easier just get the four by
four rip off the bread because i've
tried you know with the protein style
sounds good it is so hard to eat it it's
just it gets a little soggy
it is good you like barely missed the
bread
you don't miss a break for anybody that
hasn't been to an in and out i mean i've
been i feel sorry for your son we travel
around the places great pizza places and
great places but i don't think that
there's a place like in and out in the
united states no man that's not an in
and out i gotta say though i mean i love
me some minute now i don't want to be
sacrilegious here pero
i've been going to shake shack lately uh
yeah there's uh also the habits they had
a burger the habit has burgers like from
back in the day oh i've been wanting to
way back
almost like you get at a picnic yeah
where hey we used to use a piece of
white bread as a bun with some
mayonnaise and some cheese
i didn't have mustard and cheese i
didn't have a homemade bun on a burger
until i was in my 30s i think
that wasn't my joke where it says uh hot
dog boy it's a roman meal sauce
it's the same [ __ ] that's what my
grandmother said the same [ __ ] it's the
same yeah
i think the first hamburger ever made in
america was made in a toast and a
hamburger and a regular sliced bread
right there that makes sense yeah it's
in connecticut but listen if you use
regular bread or whatever meat you know
vegan meat whatever it's the you get
that when you're getting that weenie on
the end of the porn
that's so good i used to like that [ __ ]
man like five weenies sliced in half you
put them in a sandwich yeah yeah yeah
but they have all that stuff the vegan
stuff that yeah like that tastes like
the same like like in the back of the
day like if you had anything that was
good for you had a lot of flavor not
like not like yeah yeah it was bad i
love anything dude in la i love going to
vegan spots because i'm not a vegan and
i don't even try to be pero the vegan
spots like they got to show up like they
got they got to compete with all the
[ __ ] other restaurants and so they
like the dishes that they got at these
vegan spots are out of control yeah like
i love what's it soups all that stuff oh
my god it's so good it's like you can't
tell i'm like damn like i remember was
this there was like a fast food vegan
spot that used to be in where i near my
place where i live
no i'm in culver city
and it was like right there in downtown
culver for a bit but they have their
original creation and they closed hey
and you don't miss any of the flavor hub
like like nice i like chili with like
onions and cheese same thing right yeah
they had a mac and cheese burger that
they would put mac and cheese on a
[ __ ] burger with barbecue sauce that
was so good all vegan
i know that place they had the oklahoma
burger i think so yeah they give you
they put a little fried pickle right on
top right
i think so yeah i'm forgetting the name
of it it's been a while since it was
there that [ __ ] was delicious i i i
didn't miss the meat i was like well my
wife she was raised vegan too though oh
really she was not vegan when she met me
because i got it to jack of the box
number five with extra cheese
what's that number five ultimate
cheeseburger i thought
clothes it was the
the extra fried
spicy chicken sandwich
by the way correct on the uh the first
burger in america 1895 new haven
connecticut place called louise lunch uh
he would serve between two pieces of
toast
yeah bro their oven is them their ovens
are made they're like the stacked ovens
so
they gotta open it up like that and just
take the meat out oh really
but it's just a bun a no ketchup right
no ketchup bun pickle and lettuce no
thanks just two pieces of toast it looks
like i'm here oh that's it yeah i still
think that brother's gonna be as good as
jim's
number the gyms hey
astro
astro burger georges have you been to
georges in in boyle heights
they got a pastrami burger
washington pastrami there's good
pastrami out here yeah man different
than the west coast
houston different than the east coast
washington soto and they used to sell a
hockey hockey puck burger yeah the
hockey burger right there on soto they
they by
they're closed now oh they're closed oh
yeah yeah it was about probably three
years ago three four years ago
[ __ ]
that's got you they threw them good play
how come they closed over there because
that sears closed and everything kind of
went away over there
ah it may have been bad business
they were dying down there
bad business they were closed at two
though yeah they were they were open at
five o'clock at three p.m so you wanna
you wanna know that burger at midnight
or yeah
they were good friends with the people
over stevens the owner of course
the kevin bacon of food over there six
degrees of separation it must be greek
good all right man listen guys what's up
fool it's been uh
it's been fun for me it really happened
i had a great great great good to sit
with you man it's always good to sit
with felipe
hell yeah so [ __ ] this podcast is what's
up for everybody what's up full podcast
i don't have a podcast but you can
follow me on instagram
bro and what other hey what
have you gotten let's check in with the
messages have you gotten from instagram
about the podcast every kiss in your ass
no no everything's still you know
they're i got probably the nastiest
[ __ ]
message i've ever had
somebody wants to be friends i should be
dead they're gonna before they kill me
they're gonna get to my wife they could
do all kinds of [ __ ] because richie's
alive because richie's dead and i'm
alive well the the richard ramirez uh
that's probably the [ __ ] felipe
they're they're their fans
they're probably uh some hood red hat
food rats there you go no no but he has
a birthday he has fans man like yeah
he's been going for 20 years he
a lot a lot of people say a lot of good
things about the show
so it's it's all good all right awesome
gran
thanks everybody are you still on those
dating avenues
you're trying to get
there's something in here
just look around all right all right
thank you guys
what's up thank you all right marvin
thank you thank you guys thank you very
much
my regards your wife
you